ذكرت سوريا للتو،
ويذهلني أن سوريا كانت ضحية حرب
على مدى سنوات عديدة، أعني
انتهاكات فظيعة لحقوق الإنسان، وكانت إيران
متورطة، وكانت روسيا متورطة، وفي
وقت ما، قال القطريون إن الأمير قال
في عام 2018 إن المنطقة لا تستطيع ذلك.  نحن لا
نتسامح مع مجرم حرب مثل بشار
الأسد، ومع ذلك فقد
تلقى ترحيبا حارا في القمة العربية في مايو، وفي الواقع
موقفنا بشأن سوريا قلناه
بوضوح شديد عندما كان هناك قرار
بإعادة سوريا إلى الجامعة العربية،
موقفنا يظل كما هو.  نرى أننا
ما زلنا لا نرى أي شيء
يجعله مؤهلاً للعودة إلى
الجامعة العربية. لا يمكننا ذلك، لا نريد كسر
الإجماع على القرار لأنه في
نهاية المطاف لن يكون هناك تصويت واحد.
الأمر يتعلق بهذا الأمر ونحاول أن نشرح
موقفنا، الدول العربية،
الدول العربية الأخرى لديها
وجهة نظر مختلفة عنا،
لذلك لم نرغب في الاعتراض على هذا
القرار في الجلسة نفسها ولكننا
أوضحنا تمامًا أن التطبيع
بين الدول وسوريا سيكون كذلك  يكون
قرار كل دولة ونحن
نقف بنفس الموقف
لقد ذكر سموه للتو أنه في
خطابه لا يمكننا أن
نتسامح مع مجرمي الحرب، لا
يمكننا أن نرى أن الشعب السوري لا يزال
يعاني ونعطي
الحكومة هناك تنازلاً
للتحرك.  ومن أجل التطبيع،
نرى أن السبيل الوحيد للمضي قدمًا هو التوصل إلى
حل سياسي هناك. ووفقًا
للمجتمع الدولي، فإن
قرارات المجتمع الدولي رقم
تسلط الضوء بشكل واضح للغاية على
التحول السياسي والحل السياسي
وهذا لا يحدث ولا يمكننا
مكافأة أي شخص على عدم القيام بذلك.  تنفيذ
قرارات مجلس الأمن في قطر في
الدوحة تحت رعاية
حكومتكم، كما تعلمون، كانت هناك اجتماعات
انتهت قبل عامين
بتسليم الولايات المتحدة
أفغانستان لطالبان
ولم يفوا بأي من
وعودهم خاصة فيما يتعلق بالمرأة  والفتيات
في التعليم
ذهبت إلى قندهار والتقيت
بالزعيم الأصولي هناك
ماذا خرجت منه ماذا
قال كيف حاولت أن تشرح جيدا
أعتقد أن هناك جانبين في هذا
المسيحي عندما أه
عندما تنظر إلى الاتفاقية  الاتفاق في حد ذاته
هو انسحاب آمن
للقوات الأمريكية وتبادل
الالتزامات بمكافحة الإرهاب
والالتزامات بعدم توفير ملاذ آمن
للجماعات الإرهابية وتمثل
تهديدًا للولايات المتحدة أو لأي
دولة أخرى في العالم
وكان ذلك برمته.  الاتفاق المبني
على مناقشاتي في قندهار لقد
كنا واضحين للغاية إذا كنت تريد أن تكون
جزءًا من المجتمع الدولي
فأنت بحاجة إلى التعاون معنا، عليك
أه
العمل معنا معًا من أجل أن تكون
بلادك دولة إسلامية حديثة
هو بلد مسلم حيث يُسمح للنساء
ويفتخرون بأنهم جزء نشط من
المجتمع، فهم منتجون للغاية، فهم
قادة ووزراء وسفراء، وهم
على جميع المستويات في المدارس الشفهية الحربية،
وهم يفوقون عدد الرجال في
التعليم العالي رغم ذلك،
ونحن  اتفقت معهم على أننا نحتاج
على الأقل على نطاق أصغر إلى
تحريك الأمور أه إعادة السماح للنساء بالعمل
مرة أخرى في المنظمات غير الحكومية وتقديم
المساعدة للعائلات الأخرى في
أفغانستان، لقد وعدوا بأنهم
سيسمحون للنساء بالعمل والاستمرار في التمتع
بالحقوق التي  كان لديهم ثم
بالطبع لم يفعلوا،
ويبدو أن زعيم هونزادا يعتقد
أنه هو
التجسيد الحي للإسلام الحقيقي،
لذلك أراك تبتسم إلى حد ما عندما
تخبره أن الإسلام في الواقع لا
يمنع المرأة من العمل و  جميع
الأنشطة الأخرى التي يمكنهم
القيام بها ماذا يقولون، أعني هل يفهمونها حتى، هل هم
في القرن الحادي والعشرين؟ حسنًا،
أنا لست زعيمًا دينيًا لأتجادل
معه حول الدين ولكن يمكنني أن أتجادل حول
سياسات الدول الإسلامية  وهو
بلدي بلد مسلم فخور
ولدينا مسموح للنساء
ولا يمنعون من الذهاب إلى العمل أو
المدرسة أو الجامعات وأعتقد أن
علماء المسلمين لهم دور أخلاقي للتعامل
معه والتحدث معه على ما أعتقد
لدينا مسؤولية
كدول إسلامية كدول في المنطقة
للتحدث بصوت عالٍ بشأن ذلك والتحدث
معه لأننا أفضل
الأشخاص الذين يمكنهم أن يشرحوا لهم أننا
جميعًا دول إسلامية وأننا
نتصرف كالمعتاد.  المجتمعات هل أنتم
متفائلون
نحن جميعا واقعيون دائما متفائلون هل يمكنني أن
أسألكم عن المثليين يبدو أن هناك
جنوب عالمي الكثير منه يستاء
من
الأخلاق الغربية والقيم أه الحقوق
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالمثليين يقولون أنك
تعرف لماذا يجب أن يلتزموا و  أنا
أتحدث عن نفسك أيضًا من خلال
المفاهيم الغربية للحقوق والتي
ظهرت أيضًا في أه
المحاولات القاسية لكأس العالم لجعل الناس لا
يرفعون علم قوس قزح
وما إلى ذلك،
وهناك شعور بأن الأمر قليل من
نوعاً ما لا تسأل ولا تخبر
الوضع في قطر ولكن الناس يعيشون
خائفين، والمثليون ومزدوجي الميل الجنسي ومغايرو الهوية الجنسانية يعيشون خائفين في
منطقتك في جميع أنحاء منطقة الخليج،
أعني أن الأمر ليس حديثًا جدًا،
ما هو الخطأ الذي
تعرفه بالفعل  قال إن
الدولة الإسلامية لا ينبغي أن تخاف من النساء،
ولا ينبغي أن تخاف منك، فأنت تعرف كل
هذه الأشياء الأخرى، ولست على علم بما يتطلبه الأمر
لجعل المثليين
مقبولين في ضوء حقوقهم ومعاملتهم
مثل الآخرين بشكل جيد.
أعتقد أولاً وقبل كل شيء أن هذا النقاش
والجدال لا يحدث في ما
يسمى بالجنوب العالمي، بل يحدث
حتى في الغرب، ويحدث في
أمريكا، ويحدث في أماكن أخرى، وفي
كل مكان، ولكن هذا يجعل الأمر
صحيحًا
فقط لإنهاء وجهة نظري هنا، قطر هي
بلد يحب مجتمعنا
الحفاظ على التقاليد وهم
فخورون جدًا بإيمانهم وهذا
شيء غير مقبول في عقيدتنا
مقارنة ذلك بالمرأة
المشاركة في المجتمع هذا
أه هذا مختلف لا يوجد شيء في
عقيدتنا  منع النساء لا ولكن
القندهاريين يقولون أن هناك نعم، هذا هو
تفسيرهم ولكن في ما
نعرفه وما نعرفه في تاريخنا
الذي نفخر به، هل توافق على أن
هؤلاء الأشخاص لهم الحق في أن يكونوا آمنين
ولا أحد منهم يأمنهم  السلامة
موضوع كما تعلم طالما أنهم
يحترمون القانون في الأماكن العامة فلا
أحد سلامتهم موضع شك، أعني أنك
لا ترى جرائم الكراهية تحدث في
قطر بسبب المثليين أو بسبب هذا
أو بسبب ذلك أه انظر إلى  سجل
تاريخ قطر في الخمسين عامًا الماضية
وقارنه فقط بأي دولة أخرى
في أوروبا،
يمكنك رؤية جرائم الكراهية في أوروبا
ضد مجتمع المثليين
بالآلاف في العام الماضي تحدث في بعض
الدول الأوروبية الحديثة ولن أذكرها
وكانت قطر صفرًا.
يقولون هل هذه هي
قوانيننا وأدوارنا وثقافتنا وأي شخص
يريد أن يأتي إلى هنا سيأتي
طالما أنه يحترمها كما يتوقعون
منا ومن أهل الفخار أن يحترموا
قوانينهم وأعرافهم أعني أننا
نسير في أوروبا في  الدولة الغربية
إذا فعلنا شيئًا يقلل من احترامنا،
نقول لشعبنا إنه
سيحاسب على ذلك لأن
وظيفتك هناك هي احترام
البلد المضيف الذي تملكه وهذا
ما نتوقعه من الآخرين  معالي
الوزير شكرا جزيلا
شكرا جزيلا